foreign
ERS with us in Washington D.C hi Tanner
how are you
good how are you better than I deserve
what's up
so my question is I'm curious about the
flexibility of spending more than 30
percent of your take-home pay on rent
found that pretty difficult to do
especially in like an urban area like DC
I live in downtown I make around 90 000
a year plus grad 23 year old
I've got about 20 000 in cash and seven
thousand uh in an investment account and
finally my only debt is around seven
seven and a half thousand in student
loans and I spent about two thousand
dollars a month in rent which is my
biggest expense expense by far but I
still find myself able to save
um and spend less on other things I'm
just curious your take on
on that approach okay well we tell folks
to put 25 percent of the take-home pay
aside for housing and uh no math Works
in every city and in every state you
don't get a pass on math because you're
in Washington DC even though Congress
thinks you did yeah I was getting ready
to say a lot of people think they do
yeah a lot of people in DC think you do
but you don't uh and the purpose behind
it is not that 25 is Magic Tanner uh the
purpose behind it is don't be house poor
if you find yourself able to save and uh
able to invest because you keep all
other parts of your lifestyle so low
then then you're okay but if you're you
but what happens to most people is when
they've got a high cost of housing in
their budget it squeezes their budget
and there's not room to save up to buy
the next car so the next car becomes
debt and there's not room to save up for
Christmas and Christmas becomes debt and
there's not room to save up for a couch
and the couch becomes debt and because
it's all going out in house payment and
so in effect what you did is you uh you
you didn't you know by by squeezing
yourself you did that now you're telling
me you've made room in your budget and
you're doing okay then you know if
whatever you want to do rather but
here's the thing whatever you spend on
rent
is gone
I mean you're setting fire to 100 bills
in the middle of the floor and so the
more hundred dollar bills you burn in
the middle of the floor the fewer month
less money you got man I mean it's a
pretty simple equation
yeah
definitely uh definitely reduces the
about ability to buy down the road for
sure yeah yeah I mean because you're
giving it to them in rent and so I don't
know how you fix that exactly
necessarily in your situation maybe your
commute is longer maybe there's a
roommate involved or uh or maybe you
just say I'm gonna it's gonna cost me
this and it's my choice and I'm an adult
well yeah you're allowed to do all that
but our reason to give you giving you
the 25 guideline it's not a rule it's a
guideline is so that you don't become
house poor because if you're for
instance going to get a mortgage folks
in America
um the stupid mortgage company will
approve you for almost double that
and they'll approve you close to 50
percent of your take-home pay 36 percent
of your uh ratio you know and so and
that's not based on take-home pay the 36
that you can get a house payment up
close to half of your dad gum take-home
pay and there's just no way that budget
Works people and well I'm in California
well California they got to do math too
even though your Governor doesn't think
so you got to do math you know it's not
it's not an option math is math and it's
not it's not a a moral construct it's a
it's a math thing well to win Tanner in
professional World Financial World
you've got to sacrifice everybody who
wins has to sacrifice something and what
we've done here with this 25 percent you
are now having to choose do you want to
sacrifice money as Dave said by by
burning those extra hundred dollars
between the five percent that we're
talking about or do you want to
sacrifice a little bit of your time now
you're living downtown DC that's premium
and I get it you may work on the hill
who knows what you do but you're there
for a reason but if you move out into
the suburbs of Northern Virginia I know
it well yes it's a it's a headache but
we rather you sacrifice the right thing
and that's why we put this I want people
to understand what we're teaching here
it's not to be hard and fast on a rule
it's to help you learn what you need to
sacrifice and in my situation if I were
in your situation Tanner I would be
sacrificing my time not my money yeah 23
years old yeah yeah
you know I will tell you this Ken I did
it worse than he's doing it sure worse
yeah he's in good my wife and I get out
of college and here's how stupid we were
we go and rent eight we we have two dogs
we're just out of college I've got two
little jobs
we go and rent a three-bedroom
townhouse sure luxury right thanks sure
that's like five times what we needed
because we thought it was cool do you
remember what were in the extra rooms uh
nothing sure because by the time we
finish paying the freaking rent we had
no money yeah so what we ended up doing
was moving into a little one bedroom uh
apartment in a questionable uh I don't
know what those ladies down the hall
were doing in a questionable situation
and um you were hoping you weren't on a
Vice episode and I'm telling you and uh
we lived there for a year but it was one
third the rent that we were paying
before one third
and so that'd be like you had an 1800
rent and we moved down to a 600 rent
right you know kind of thing today in
today's dollars it was a lot less than
that in the back when the dinosaurs
roamed the Earth but yeah but oh my gosh
wow I did the exact same crap no I get
it but but I wanted something nice and I
had a job yeah and I'd gotten out of
college and I'm I deserved it but a lot
of 23 year olds that are in a very
similar situation Tanner now just think
about this if he gets a roommate
and now he's saving let's just call it a
thousand dollars a month
okay splitting the rent he's paying off
that student loan debt of seven thousand
dollars really really fast and now he's
just stacking money
stacking cash man so much